he was the head of state of the Khmer
Rouge and its most public figure 91 year
old Q sompon will spend the rest of his
life Behind Bars after a un-backed
tribunal upheld his conviction for
crimes against humanity and genocide
against the Vietnamese minority
he's already serving another life
sentence also for crimes against
humanity in relation to the forced
evacuation of Phnom Penh between 1975
and 1979 as many as 2 million people
died many of them tortured or starved to
death the brutality of the Khmer rouge's
four-year Reign has not been forgotten
even though the regime was ousted more
than 40 years ago
hundreds of people turned up to hear the
verdict including Buddhist monks and
Khmer Rouge survivors
I am happy I want justice so that what
happened in the past won't happen again
we want it to be over
had tried to argue he was merely a
figurehead with no real power but
prosecutors say he was one of those most
responsible
this is uh the story called The for the
Cambodian purple and specially for the
victim of the khmeru regime and also the
international criminal justice and
Humanity this is only the second case
heard by the un-backed tribunal but it's
also the last in 16 years the court has
prosecuted five Khmer Rouge officials
resulting in three convictions leading
some to question whether it's been worth
it yuk Chang researches the regime and
says the hearings which allowed
survivors and relatives of victims to
testify have offered some closure it
confirmed that we can live after
genocide that we can move move on and we
can rebuild
we can put back what has been lost
ultimately the tribunal's Legacy may be
its contribution to National
reconciliation Florence Louis Al Jazeera